Nella notte tra il 15 e il 16 ottobre
2005 un rumore rompe il silenzio è un
allarme l'allarme della civica scuola di
teatro Paolo Grassi uno o più individui
si sono intrufolati in questa scuola e
hanno rubato tre oggetti
preziosi Benvenuti a notte
fonda
[Musica]
pupazzi i protagonisti di questa puntata
Tutti li abbiamo o tutti li abbiamo
avuti e ogni tanto diamo per scontata la
loro importanza nella nostra vita perché
ci sono svariati motivi per cui uno può
avere o regalare dei pupazzi per esempio
alle elementari se è innamorato della
ragazzina in secondo banco e quindi
compri uno di quegli orsacchiotti che
tieni in mano un cuoricino con scritto I
love you glielo regali e lei non ti caga
di pezza oppure vuoi comprare questa
rana verde fosforescente gigante perché
sta perfettamente nell'arredo
dell'ufficio oppure uno dei motivi più
importanti per cui si hanno i pupazzi è
ricordare la propria infanzia come
Angelica dei ragrets la mia prima Crush
oppure ami i videogiochi Ma vuoi avere
anche un piccolo ricordo che la vita fa
schifo e quindi compri un Isaac oppure
sei un influencer e vuoi spendere i tuoi
soldi per comprare cose che non hai mai
avuto nella tua
infanzia poi ci sono quelli che non sai
perché esistano e non sai perché tu li
abbia comprati Ma l'hai fatto fai un
viaggio in autostrada ti fermi in
Autogrill e compri nello Lasino che
canta O sole mio
[Musica]
Dio
mio è anche difficile Non dire banalità
o raccontare cose scontate quando si
parla della cosiddetta Tv dei ragazzi la
casa di tutti i pupazzi più importanti
della nostra infanzia qualche anno fa
Dario Moccia fece un documentario sulla
TV dei ragazzi piccolo aneddoto su
questo documentario quando si parla con
Lupo Lucio dietro la telecamera ci sono
anche io a casa sua mi ricordo quando
ero piccolo tornavo da scuola e giravo
immediatamente su Italia 7 Gold perché
c'era Ken Shiro e poi subito dopo giravo
verso Mediaset Perché iniziava bim buom
bam E credo che il primo vero boom di
pupazzi in Italia sia Arriv
negli anni 60 con il Carosello Mamma Rai
stava aprendo il suo secondo canale e la
televisione per gli italiani ormai era
un falò dove radunarsi per guardare ogni
sorta di intrattenimento televisivo
sportivo e
[Musica]
pubblicitario Salve a tutti voi non
avete la minima idea di quanti pupazzi
ci fossero in quel periodo parliamo di
gente come
Lo Scoiattolo Galileo e gli animatti
Galileo era un bruco e gli
animatti ipotizzo i suoi amici matti in
culo la scimmia carcadè Il Tucano
elzeviro e brigantina tre amici che
viaggiano in una bolla di sapone
e i Pirilli piccoli uomini che vivono in
un paese chiamato
Pirillo sen Sen poi
dimenticarci di
Pippo nel
1967 l'agenzia pubblicitaria Armando
Testa creò per il Carosello dell'epoca
Pippo questo ippopotamo blu protagonista
della pubblicità della Lines dei
pannolini per bambini questa agenzia con
sede a Torino ha ben pensato di mettere
una gigantografia di questo Pippo sul
tetto dell'edificio che ti guarda D alto
verso il basso come se fosse un Kaiju
gigantesco che deve distruggere Torino
ed è probabilmente l'unica mascotta al
mondo a vedersi dai
[Musica]
satelliti uno dei punti cardine di
questa narrazione è Paolo
Bonolis alcuni di voi lo conosceranno
per essere entrato nel Guinness World
Record per il maggior numero di parole
dette in un minuto storia vera altri tra
gli anni 80 e gli anni 90 per essere
stato il conduttore dell'emblema della
Tv dei ragazzi Bim Bum Bam lui ed
Emanuela blanchard che se vi steste
chiedendo che fine avesse fatto adesso
insegna Tai molto figo hanno condotto
questo programma che per anni ha
allietato i pomeriggi dei bambini
presentandogli cartoni animati e
raccontandogli le bellezze del mondo ma
non sono gli unici due cond di Bim Bum
Bam non dimentichiamoci il vero
protagonista di questa storia One la
mascot di Italia
1 non è l'unica mascot Mediaset Perché
se voi ci pensate One si chiama One
perché la mascot d'Italia 1 ma abbiamo
anche for la mascot di Rete 4 e Five la
mascot di Canale 5 e i loro tre sono gli
oggetti preziosi che quella notte del
2005 sono stati rubati dalla
scuola Ora cercherò di ricostruire i
fatti di quella notte al meglio delle
mie possibilità con tutte le
informazioni che ho trovato on e non
come abbiamo già raccontato Nella notte
tra il 15 il 16 ottobre uno o più ladri
si sono intrufolati nella civica scuola
di teatro Paolo Grassi non sappiamo
quante persone fossero sappiamo soltanto
che a un certo punto scatta l'allarme il
custode va a vedere cosa fosse successo
e lui a detta sua non è successo nulla
fuori
dall'ordinario ovviamente il giorno dopo
esce fuori la notizia che quello che in
realtà è successo è stato Il rapimento
di tre
noti pupazzi abbiamo
One
abbiamo Four e abbiamo ovviamente il
bisione
Five sono state rubate le copie di
questi tre pupazzi amati da tutti quanti
e esce fuori la notizia e molti articoli
di giornali la riportano rapiti one4 A5
gli storici pupazzi rubati a Milano
furto o rapimento non si sa ed
effettivamente noi non abbiamo
moltissime informazioni su quello che è
successo però la ricostruzione più
grande l'ha fatta il sito tv Blog perché
non appena è successa questa cosa qua
loro hanno fatto una cosa molto
particolare il 19 Ottobre Lanciano un
appello Lanciano un appello a tutti
quanti i lettori Il Fatto One F4 ovvero
i tre pupazzi della media di chiunque
bla bl bla sono stati rbati Vi prego
signori rapitori Paolo e Manuela non
dormono da du giorni Paolo Emanuela sono
Paolo Bonolis uel
blanchar e da lì tutta la gente inizia a
sapere di questa cosa qu e il
2ob esce fuori
uno un commento sotto uno di questi post
del presunto rapitore per la scomparsa
di One vi posso annunciare che ben
presto vi manderò delle foto che
mostrano dove attualmente si trova il
dolce cagnolino rosa e Credetemi sta
benissimo e chiude con un A presto
simagi Ora io non ho idea di cosa sia
sagi forse una frase che diceva for Five
forse la filma forse il nome del
rapitore il nick del
rapitore ma non lo possiamo
sapere il 26 ottobre
[Musica]
invece TV Blog la porca e il 26
ottobre alla redazione di tv Blog
arrivano misteriosamente tre fotografie
di Ju rapito Questa è la prima possiamo
vedere One sdraiato a letto con le
lenzuola bianche il muro bianco
purtroppo non ci dà nessuna informazione
con Creta sembra quasi una foto del
rapimento di Aldo Moro la seconda
fotografia è questa un primo piano di
One molto scura si vedono dei rami si
vedono delle foglie ma purtroppo questa
foto in controluce non ci dà
informazioni ed infatti la terza è
purtroppo simile è uguale a quella di
prima ma molto meglio illuminata perché
probabilmente il rapitore ha scoperto
l'iso o il flash si vedono meglio le
foglie si vede un pezzo di balcone ma
purtroppo non abbiamo i mezzi per fare
quello che facevano gli americani con i
video di Bin Laden dove analizzavano i
pezzi delle Grotte la redazione di tv
Blog dopo aver visto queste fotografie
chiede in ginocchio delle prove un po'
più concrete Perché queste fotografie
avrebbe potuto farle chiunque ed infatti
il 21 novembre più di un mese dopo al
rapimento arriva la fotografia di Juan
c'è lui con in mano l'espresso
di quel giorno lì Purtroppo la foto si
trova nella condizione che vedete con il
logo di Chi l'ha visto perché sono tutti
burloni Ma noi possiamo vedere uno
sfondo migliore c'è questa collina
Erbosa che va verso il mare siccome Juan
è stato rapito a Milano possiamo dire
che in questo mese mi sa che i rapitori
hanno telato potrebbe essere Sardegna
potrebbe essere Puglia potrebbero essere
le Onolulu purtroppo non abbiamo più
informazioni e ci sono delle domande che
ancora non hanno risposta Chi ha rapito
i pupazzi Come mai ci sono le fotografie
solo di One ma non di F e di five e
soprattutto perché non si è più saputo
nulla per farvi capire l'importanza di
questi pupazzi rapiti Loro sono la
versione ufficiale dei pupazzi creata
dal gruppo 80 l'azienda numero uno per
la creazione di pupazzi televisivi in
Italia Potete farvi un giro volendo
nella loro pagina Facebook per vedere un
sacco di fotografie di backstage di come
vengono costruiti questi pupazzi questo
per esempio è mister Pipolo Cazzetto Se
invece voleste approfondire la storia vi
consiglio il libro di Luca Lomi pupazzi
Story che racconta il mondo dei pupazzi
in TV ed è proprio in questo libro che
ho scoperto l'azienda My puppit che ha
creato Karim
[Musica]
pupazzo una storia misteriosa un enigma
indecifrabile Questo è Il rapimento di
Juan questo è notte
[Musica]
fonda Che brividi che mi mette notte
fonda Ma sai cosa mi mette ancora più
brividi non avere Nord VPN che ti
protegge la connessione eh sì Non fate i
pupazzi non connettetevi alle reti
pubbliche senza criptare i vostri dati
puoi addirittura connetterti ad un IP
diverso da quello del tuo paese
d'origine diglielo se attivi la threat
Protection puoi proteggerti da siti
dannosi e pop-up invasivi come un
braccio
nell'ano usa il codice sconto Yotobi Per
usufruire delle offerte ed avere 4 mesi
extra sui piani B
Wow